okay so we are gonna talk about we
usually do this but we're gonna do a V
log on a show we watched went all the
way through Netflix called disenchanted
I was weather gets disappointed because
that's what all the videos say they just
out in Big Lake like disappoint yeah I
feel like so clever for me set myself up
there yeah but no okay so the is
obviously from Matt Groening and did
Simpsons and Futurama where did those
shows go no way no it no at all I'm not
a pedigree really to start strongly but
Barry's FICA Simpsons even though a lot
of people hands not that you know funny
and more what's going on too long no no
I'm joking
ratings pedigrees amazing so no it's
still on and he didn't do but the critic
but a lot of people did the Simpsons did
the critic and you know I was very good
and Futurama was never a huge hit but
then it got canceled a lot of people
want it back brought it back cult
favorite yeah and and that was a it was
like and it went okay but it still
didn't have the huge hit ratings that it
wanted even with a product that but
you're right cult it send out a little
bit but nowhere to the same spectacular
degree because Simpsons is trash right
now like it's a scrape and bottom of the
barrel but you know Futurama I think
even in its last you know gasps and the
movies and stuff I was like I still
found it pretty funny
uh and Futurama definitely there was it
was like Simpsons over there was like
this span of a few years or it's like
wow everything just was perfect but well
well now what I like about Futurama even
though I do have issues with it is that
was very much about ideas here's just a
future where you can kind of do anything
and I really like that so I get really
excited for disenchanted and you know
the reviews for it have been you know it
kind of up and down and the short
version of it is that I like the way
start out like the way it ended and for
a while I kind of felt like I was
watching it out obligate
like well okay I like migrating I like
you know this animation this style of
humor let me just get through it cuz you
know there's never been an awful episode
like that was trash that was really
really bad and then when I got to the
end I'm like I'm glad I watched all of
that and I really want more I'm at you
kind of angry where it stopped cuz I'm
like oh you were just getting going so I
have issues but I'm glad I sat through
it there was never an episode where I'm
like there was no laughs you know there
was always a couple laugh out loud
moments with each episode I watched it a
little bit late because so many people I
knew had already started watching it and
it was like nearly universal just not
that good it's just I'm I'm like I think
I when I asked you at what point I I
said what are you on him what do you
think he's like oh yeah yeah I'm on I'm
on episode 7 and like there was one
funny thing but it's it's really not
you're like yeah you're you were really
like and everybody I know is like no
scary I one person's like meh craning
should know better because he's done
better things and there's no excuse for
this because Futurama was clunky oh and
you shouldn't make I argue that's
actually why you would make that mistake
is if you've done this before and now
you're trying to do this on Netflix
because some things just don't translate
to Netflix like they do on network
television where you watch it just once
a week but so I went in with lowered
expectations like really low I'm like
wow okay well this is gonna suck I guess
always give it a try for a lark I think
that helped me out because I think I
enjoyed it a lot more than other people
did just because I thought well this is
gonna be just terrible
and with those zero expectations I was
like it's actually pretty funny
yeah it's clunky like there are a number
of jokes it was like particularly the
first episodes like it was very 50/50
50% of the jokes hit and the 50% that
didn't we're just like awkward
I've had them silence bombs where it's
like you could hear the crickets
chirping and like they're waiting it's
like they're giving that pause for you
as the audience member to laughs only
you're sitting there not laughing now
here's a little bit I'll say what I
kinda liked almost about that is that
there
very I find there's a big difference
between Simpsons now and Futurama and
these Mac rating shows and Mac training
sense of humor Matt grading sense of
humor especially if you read like the
life like this hell you know and stuff
like that uh his satire is a little more
vague you know something like the
suicide boost in Futurama that feels
very Mack raining there's a line in the
first episode where the elf goes so this
is war I don't love it you know that's
very matte grainy where a lot of the
humor is very much believed that we're
gonna no no no like we're gonna satirize
Church we're gonna satirise they're like
you know exactly the specific thing it's
satirizing and that's great too that's
what simpson says is what the drama does
a lot of the time that's not that's the
issue no no I'm not I think that I'm
saying that I actually could have used
more of that as the show progressed and
the other thing I could have used that
we finally get near the end we in the
beginning and then we get near the end
and the middle just leaves a lot of it
out it's a continuing story which I
thought for Netflix especially would
have been really exciting and really
cool again only getting beginning in the
end he's old school he is stuck in the
mindset I think still of oh well it's
like Simpsons or Futurama
you know we got some filler episodes we
do this we slowly weave a story as time
goes on and you're right on Netflix when
you're binge watching something it
doesn't work because you're watching a
lot of people watch these things all in
a row and that's when the cracks start
to show like God has taken forever but
the the sand tears have that's not the
problem it's just it's bad comic timing
it's as simple as that a lot of the
jokes particularly in episode one and
then on and off through a lot of the
middle episodes are just poorly timed
and execute it like it's just they're
poorly cut they're not well put together
and they have these awkward silences
afterwards like the writers were just
like this is gonna be hilarious the
reality of time for the audience to
laugh and what nothing I just sat there
just an awkward silence like wow that
joke didn't land but the weird thing is
they're jokes so perfectly cut and timed
in this that I just lost my shit and I
can't deposit because it was so perfect
and they would happen like just randomly
like
I thought episode 2 was really pretty
strong the episode with Hansel and
Gretel
was amazing when the story kicks in the
final episode itself isn't that funny
but the two leading into it when the
story you know kicks in like those two
episodes are very well put together and
cut and had great comic timing so but
that's the thing I remember that being
an issue yeah with early Simpsons and
early Futurama like they both early
Futurama yeah they both did that and
it's like I don't know if that's
graining x' fault or if this is just the
first season of most things you're just
working out the kinks but I felt slowly
they got better and it was still
inconsistent particularly in the middle
but by the last three I was on board and
even though even though the last one
wasn't that funny
it was okay because the plot made up for
it I'm like okay I'm invested in this
play and that's not one game to with you
know it with the first one even though I
know you're talking about with some of
the humor and stuff where it's like okay
you're supposed to laugh at that if you
don't there's this long awkward pause
but then other scenes where it's like
the humor it doesn't feel like some of
the jokes don't feel like it's supposed
to be a zing like that it's kind of like
Oh like that's just kind of like it's
supposed to be a little awkward it's
supposed to be a little off and I was
liking that because I haven't really
seen a Futurama or Simpsons really do
that maybe early Simpsons a little bit
but then you're right you the
traditional Simpsons stuff where it's
like joke joke joke and you're right if
they don't hit they let these kind of
really really dry style of writing I
love so when you did it right it was
fine yes there were so many times where
it's just like it's not that Oh
always trying something new and it's
satirical it's just it's a poorly
delivered joy yeah and I think when we
hear - oh and it's really yeah dry like
some of the best stuff was the dry stuff
or even like one of my Fairlanes is just
it was the haunts of granola it's like
some crack about they're obviously gonna
be in Psych yes and suitably having you
for dinner hey Shh don't give up the
game you know it makes people nervous
when Germans that like it's like little
lion that again like I
I love bits like that or the I was going
to say what what's so weird okay like
with the continuing story
I even like when it would stir okay so
the episode starts off very kind of
conventional especially with the being
character was like she's gonna marry
someone she doesn't love
ah seem a million times but she's gonna
go off somewhere and gonna find like the
wishmaster which honestly builds up to a
joke that's not very funny but but
they're traveling they're going
somewhere else and I'm thinking like
well this is cool and now they're gonna
go get a beer oh it's gonna be alert
road trip yeah and they to the kingdom
is not a very interesting place and the
best episodes are where they go
somewhere else usually again with the
exception of the last couple where they
do this continuing story and the
continuing story even like when they
start they sort of start out of nowhere
like suddenly the king is saying you
mean we can get the elixir of life and
it's like where did that come from but
you do see it does work into the story
it works in very well but just out of
nowhere he brings it up and it's one of
those things where I felt like if you
did just do these filler episodes and
you did tie it into this continuing
story and they did travel more it would
have been really really interesting you
would have been a weird thing though
watching the final few episodes I was
like wow a lot of things I thought were
filler came back yeah that's what I mean
like they were in and they worked in
working and I liked the fact that they
came back the witch's house surrounded
in police state yeah no I agree cuz I
thought oh we're gonna go explore the
kingdom and there's a full map here and
I see what they're doing because at the
end of this they're implying oh she's
gonna see more stuff season two yeah
she'll be out of the kingdom I really
want to see a season and in retrospect
and it wider - yeah but like for the
problems faced in retrospect I don't
mind staying in the kingdom you just
needed to make that Kingdom a little
more interesting and there's there's
funny things in it that I really enjoyed
but it just wasn't quite enough but I
mean there were there were still funny
things it reminds me of like Secret of
Monkey Island like that style of humor
where we're gonna take ya period in
history in Monkey Island it's like the
Caribbean and pirates and in this one
it's like medieval fantasy and like the
news guy was always killing me
and so I I don't know I enjoyed that or
them drinking the fairy like the stage
yeah the green fairy it's like it's okay
honey I go down smooth like there was so
many like little jokes like that I'm
like okay those really work it just
needed it needed more punch and it
needed that kind of later Futurama and
I'm not gonna say later later Simpsons
but later like yes yes ins four or five
you know three that level of quick
timing quick yeah cutting there were
just too many long stretches if you're
telling some jokes and the plot wasn't
supporting it when the plot support in
the final episode was fine final
episodes not very funny
but the plot but yeah he read all the
way in the middle part of this series
that doesn't happen with the exception
of there's a couple episodes I do like
the one where she throws the party and
the Vikings invade yeah and I do like
the Hansel and Gretel episodes Origo but
I remember it was episode three an
episode I can't remember I was gonna say
five three two is where I'm like that's
what kills me it's just like I cannot
even tell you what happens in episode
three all I remember thinking was all of
a sudden I was like oh cuz at first it
was like I was pretty good the first one
is oh came the shit was really funny and
that was just like oh maybe this is what
people are talking about cuz I was like
that didn't do anything for me and I
cannot remember what even that yeah by
the yeah episode 3 I remember like
something's off something this is not
what we started with and it and it comes
back goes back and forth anyone I talk
to about this show that gets all the way
through that nobody I know loves it only
if you go online do you find people who
hate it you know because they want it
you know I think it's the really angry I
think it's the return of the Jedi of
cartoon shows where people really really
love certain scenes but then you know
there's like a box yeah but you love the
parts you love so much if you stick with
it like it does get somewhere and sadly
where it gets to isn't that like a big
punch if anything I was really pissed
off cuz I'm like no I really want to see
more but not in the good way not in the
way that's like oh that left me
satisfied it's like
we really should have been focusing out
more of this throughout the entire show
but I do really want a season two and I
think if they are going to do serve the
slower pace humor if they need jokes
that reflect it and if you're gonna do
more of the fast paced stuff again you
need jokes never feel like that this
kind of half and half you've gotta pick
one and go with a slower eye slower pace
see with them one of the best jokes in
the whole show and it was the first joke
that just made me lose my shit I had to
pause it and it's like a triple setup
and it takes its time and it builds and
it's amazing an example of when you do
the slow humor right because it's a joke
that keeps building and it's they're
trying to drain it's episode two they're
trying to drain elf oh that's like well
we can't do that well we'll drain the
pig instead and claim itself owes blood
so they bring this pig up they stick it
in and start filling this big flask and
you know Elfa is really small jump cut
one cup to the next day and the first
jump cut is the flask is like just
overflowed with blood jump cut - the
wizard that is way more blood and I
thought we were going to get out of that
little elf jump cut again and everybody
in the tower is literally in like six
inches of blood yeah wading through it
like a kiddie pool and then cut to the
king just like looks like I picked the
wrong day to wear galoshes I just lost
it because I wasn't it kept building
because I'm like oh hush it's pig's boy
it's a pig but yeah I can't remember
it's one Pig I think it was several pigs
no I no I think it was but yeah just
that jump cut I was not expecting them
to keep building the joke and then that
jump cut to just the whole room just
blood everywhere it was perfectly time
like I laughed out loud super hard at
that and like that is a slow joke that
really really works and there's a few of
them in there like that
yeah so I hope they keep like that kind
of thing up and again it was perfect
comic timing I think you with like you
know again when they try something new
it's weird when they kind of get that
Simpsons timing in the Simpsons joke I
can't act like I don't like it or it
doesn't get a laugh but I kinda liked it
morning was getting away from this and
it's like the design of that Lucy
character is not like any
yes simpson design which is great the
whole idea of like you know this
continuing story I mean I guess they did
a little bit of a Futurama like the
relationships but there's never been
like a full continuing story that went
over like the season I like that too and
again even kind of a vague humor at the
opening joke and stuff I kind of like so
it's one of those things where it's like
I kind of like want to say good keep
taking the risk keep trying something a
little different a second here and I
don't like I don't want to cramp on
voice actors because I think they're all
amazing but I I did not like the Kings
voice at all I'm like its bender it's
the this John DiMaggio John DiMaggio
doing bender like you can be like what's
that exactly bender it's really close
and it's really distracting and then
when you have an art style by Matt
graining who did Futurama and Simpsons
and you bring in Billy West playing mmm
Maurice LaMarche tress MacNeille and
like tress MacNeille I love really
distracting though because it's like you
just hear it's like oh there's Ralph
Wiggum
or there is you know the crazy hands rev
weakened whoo yeah
what did she only does like side
characters on the sense it was the crazy
cat lady yeah it she's the crazy yeah
and she does and she does they're
together as the witch and then Maurice
LaMarche who I love Maurice LaMarche
he's about my favorite voice actors but
it's him just doing that Futurama
character he played a mother mother kids
or it's all the same sort of voice now I
mean evil wizard I guess and it does
make it tougher to accept it as
something else it's yes your console
here is wrong it's really distracting
and I kind of wish like cuz particularly
like honestly I'd say all of them all of
them have incredible range and like
somebody like Maurice LaMarche it's like
you're the director you could have said
give me something different this is a
guy you did dizzy devil like you can do
like all sorts of voices and it's just
I'm just doing my Maurice LaMarche thing
like from the other it just that's
really distracting that's what makes it
feel like areas like it's future around
the light and
man if I change the voices it's not as
bad and then obviously the animation
style kind of is but I'm just like a lot
of it to me is just the voice work
sounds so familiar if you've seen the
future I think that's why like the
character probably gets the most laughs
is the Lucy it character because there's
nothing like that on that yeah that's
just in the theory there actually is and
this is where I think the voice acting
is detrimental like I go well the king
it's bender and yet really the true
bender character is Lucy he's actually
the beggar character from but with the
new voice you can't like I didn't even
think about it till like halfway through
I was like I I guess he is like an
enabling smoking drinking like he's
really probably more the bender all the
kings just you know a slob or whatever
but it so yeah I think that's a problem
that it can't be fixed now you're just
gonna have to come up with writing well
good but there's a tough spot there into
where it's like you have if there's two
characters in particular a one big time
here they're just okay where I was just
like you know I see what you're trying
to go for it but mate you didn't go all
the way the one that's like I worked out
okay it was being because you know
that's supposed to be the party animal
and I feel like there it would have been
funny if they just went full lindsay
lohan with her like just the absolute
satire party fest so then when you get
to the side moments it's a little bit
about that episode where she got drunk
as the ambassador that was pretty damn
close III wanted more of that I wanted
to get even crazy or an even waking or
getting but I feel like they want her
more to be kinda like the emotional and
that's why I mean it and it works by
would like to more if they went all the
way and then the sympathy can't comes in
a little bit more naturally but they're
like now we want to make it where it was
a surprise because and this is common a
lot of pilots I not like her voice in
episode one but it grew on me pretty
darn quickly so by about you know the
end of episode two I'm like oh that's re
night I don't even notice it now but I
remember thinking early on it was like I
don't know if her voice is doing it for
me
but but LFO elf Oh is the biggest one
that's the one for me okay no I'll tell
you
I kind of like it in spurts and then I'm
just like oh god sometimes I'm I shut up
when I first saw this character I mean
you're right about the voice that does
get grating after a while but I first
saw this character I got really excited
because literally first time he wants to
be dark yeah he's uh he's got this
conveyor belt and he puts himself on the
conveyor belt this girl outfits like
kissing him all then gets to him and
kisses him and they start making out no
that's not our way and he says I I want
to be cynical I wanna like means that I
want to be miserable and I am what is
this idea yeah I want to see him go into
the land I want to meet up with Lucy and
Lucy maybe like teach him wrong things
or in the bad way about how to be bad
you can have this great parallel with
these two the one who knows bad things
are the one who wants to learn bad
things but because he knows bad things
he's constantly sabotaging him or maybe
teaching him good thing Lee you could do
so much with that and as soon as he gets
to the real world you know if he gets a
little hello hi and it's like where did
that character go ha ha ha ha I will
tell you it's called writing yourself
into a corner and they had two
characters and that would have been like
that because Lucy is already doing that
no but I
I feel Yuka had enough variation because
he's learning and I feel like it this
guy already knows where this guy would
be learning so he could constantly be
sanitizing him the problem is
Lucy is already teaching her how to be
bad so Lucy's gonna teach the elf how to
be bad then or or she beans gonna teach
it's something that could all bond over
to like the three of them when I just
know that I hate her because they're
already kind of the esocast
I think I will say this it was a bad
setup but the reason they dropped it I
think it would just get redundant really
fast it's like well then this is all the
same I feel like what good writing you
can have this er like be the one common
I think light binds them together
I think the second they put Lucy and
they suddenly realize that shit this is
all this is good at like no cuz that's
why fun too but that London I feel like
you can make it work because after a
while and even like you know it's like
it's like he's happy but he really wants
to learn this stuff at least have a
wanting to learn that stuff and he does
it he just drops it he's just constantly
happy well you should
yeah well you shouldn't want to thing
Marty doesn't were already 12 episodes
into it how long do you think you're
just gonna be able to pull that well he
still has to be happy because you
actually need think about it you do need
happy foot but that he wants to work for
12 episodes he's gonna learn but still
be kind of happy and this is gonna
continue through the rest of the series
like I wanna see I would like you know
as you know get blowing snow not just
comedic because it doesn't matter anyway
that could be interesting anywhere
because you can't have him be truly
unhappy because then you've got
basically their main of a shame you
learned
maybe he discovers that like you know oh
you know maybe there is something that
can be nice but like you know in a fair
amount not 24/7 like we're 12 episodes I
I will say this yeah no that wouldn't
fix it I'm just not sure Elfa is a
fantastic idea to begin like the else
themselves are really funny hmm I just
feel they needed to be some other angle
you know even if he's coming from there
and he is if you want to do that that
you don't need the exact opposite like
an angel and a devil if you want to do
that the beauty of a character like
Lucy's you can continue that on
indefinitely and it's still funny
because you can see what they're doing
or he's like what did I help someone who
wears this gummy but you know where
they're gonna do I mean a lot of fun
he's still yeah well bender was kind of
the same way like eventually sometimes
he'll do the right thing um so he's I
feel like Lucy's chaotic neutral but
yeah Lucy's my favorite character in the
whole thing and it's and it's an easy
character it's slightly lazy because it
writes itself
but that character you can go in and
patoot it like a I don't think elf oh is
the well he wants to learn how to be bad
it's once they set it up at you got two
miserable characters already Lucy and
bean and most other people seem
miserable it's like elf Oh provides some
of that little glimmer of hope and I
just I just don't see it going anywhere
I feel like you could have had that like
if you make my god I want to be dark
like maybe he rubs off on them
goodness while they serve rub off on him
sore in the pen and living a bit it's
like hey I feel like there was no been
much
okay the only way I would see this where
he used to be much funnier if in trying
to be bad he always just ends up still
doing good yeah something like that
something like that but yeah he's
definitely that I I feel like he's
definitely the weakest character even
though the elves are freaking funny as
hell yeah that that episode where they
went like to war I the second they
whipped out like spoiler alert I guess
the second they whipped out the candy
canes with the swords yeah I was just
like yes this is like on top of each
other yeah the Giants is a man that's
just a fun idea to no no no or what's it
gnomes oh no no no you're right you're
right when they have the little battle
later no oh yeah elf O's problem is he's
the Seinfeld of the show which is what
makes him funny is everybody like
reacting off of him hmm like I don't
even know if Seinfeld's a good
comparison but it's like when Lucy's
talking about alpha-1 beans talk about
of when they talk about what a klutzy is
when they you know are basically
thumping on him and like doing awful
things to him that's what makes elf Oh
funny elf Oh himself to me isn't that
funny this is more everybody's reaction
to him like that
well that bit where he they're like just
like The Hobbit tracking Lucy doesn't
The Hobbit are he's like yeah he he
rolled down this hill walked straight
into this tree then he walked over here
straight into this other tree then he
tripped cried a little then lost a shoe
to this deranged squirrel on this girls
like ha and runs off with a shoe you
know judging by these height marks I
think L feel it's ballast here like that
stuff was hilarious and the funny thing
is you never saw LFO do any yeah it's
almost rip shins what you know and again
we won't get into spoilers with this but
the I knew something had to be working
with this show when I got to those last
three episodes and and there was two
legit surprises to me I think it was
like the third to last or second to last
the first one involving the you know
they they they sent around the Statue of
the mother and those that watch the show
know know what I'm talking about
so that was one surprise and then
there's
so surprise where the main character has
to make a choice and it's not like the
obvious choice that you hear all the
time like you know spider-man will you
take the children your girlfriend is it
that what's the one and only surprise in
the home yeah no everything else and
they don't have everything have all
these other twists in the final episode
and yeah all of them you can predict
them yes they're still in charge no
you're right but it's very just like ok
I see exactly what they're going but but
but you know I know who did it like the
main character has to be that was
actually shocked that that choice was
being suggested in a show like this ya
know in a show like you know Simpson say
you know maybe Futurama would try
something like this by me like never
really seeing the choice like that and
then when the choice is made I'm
legitimately surprised and when you see
kind of what they do it then even it
kind of what they end the season on I'm
like well okay well this choice is me
but something has to happen here before
this season ends and it doesn't and well
sure I'm sure they'll do it in the next
season but it's one of those things
where I'm just like huh or if they
really have the balls actually what
would that actually be fast considering
we were just talking about maybe they
would be the better idea that would be
really fascinating but yeah but yeah
it's one of those things were it's like
by the time I got to the end I'm like
okay I want to see a season 2 of this I
actually really do want to see a season
2 run I want to see it with some of
these changes made overall the style of
comedy like I think my favorite episode
outside of too and then Hansel and
Gretel was that first one that kicked
off the plot like it was like an episode
9 or somebody was like about three
episodes from me well the guy had the
Zelda thing where they go into the
desert where they go yeah they go into
the they they follow like they there's
an outline on a map and they go from
place to place I'm like finally
adventuring yeah like we're finding
hidden treasure and shit and that was an
amazing episode overall like yeah I'd
say that the humor is very dry very
Monkey Island ish when it works it
really really works or some great visual
gags all throughout the thing but yeah I
think what I love most about the show is
how ruthlessly mercilessly and
needlessly dark it it's it's very
reflective of medieval times it's like
life
is cheap and like they're just throwaway
jokes where she pulls the lever and
people always fall into the ocean when
you pull the lever it said the castles
over the ocean then it'll be like wow
you murdered them in cold blood just
fall into the ocean they'll be fine you
just hear this
oh I guess the tide was out I could have
used even more of that yeah seven heads
on the pike the elves going to war the
pig's blood see yeah I mean the bottom
line both agree or a poisoned water
found that I was getting no ashes just
oh it's one of those things where it's
like the more you can kind of distance
yourself from simpson's with the
exception of the comic timing I think
that's the one thing you can keep from
Simpsons keep the comic time and critic
and Futurama and uh and then make it
darkest if you trauma hit a few episodes
backward dark yeah the dog one still I'm
just like Jesus yeah Christ the one
where Lila keeps like hallucinating and
fries coffin his out in space there are
a few where it got like well it's kind
of spooky stuff but for the most part I
didn't find Futurama excessively dark no
this one feels like you can go that far
the episode where bender was God to
people living on his ass that was that
was a good dark and now that was a good
dark one but it's just like the Simpsons
that weren't quite allowed to do that
this one I'd say yeah keep going with
the darkness yeah that's what makes me
laugh the most and Lucy's a great
character for that and then just the
wanton death and destruction that the
number of side characters that are just
like the nights we've lost many good
nights and it's true they don't come
back they're just dead and they die
often in comical ways which is yeah yeah
yeah and you know I'll even argue that
the because there is an emotional side
to the show and it works best when it
does come from that darkness like the
choice she has to make at the end or in
the last couple episodes I really like
at some plank him or what it is but I
think it's like when he's trying to
teach her to be tougher and like she's
gonna be this executioner and stuff and
I think at the very old God yeah that
episode well what she says at the end
something all in the lines of
you know if you ever try to
something-something again I'm gonna like
eat your insides with my buck teeth or
something the Kings like that's my girl
and it's like yeah that's what's really
sick and dark but it's kind of touching
to like that's where I feel it works
best it's like strangely enough in that
darkness you can find these bits of
heart every the fact that executions
much like medieval times like
entertainment yeah you swing the axe
super so maybe laughs so how do know
some I'm watching the same execution
that you are I'm just yeah well what a
great joke is it sorry kind of
satirizing Braveheart with the eggs
totally coming down but then what they
reveal it's in real doing in a real time
because she's afraid to kill somebody
yeah um and again it's very dark it's
very funny and you know what it's sad
when at the end of the game so the King
gives himself the parenting of the year
where is that yeah so I give this award
for great parenting it's very Trump yeah
yeah yeah I feel the more that darkness
and the more the continuing story you
can do with the exception of a comic
timing I say the more you can kind of
distance yourself from Simpsons I think
the better and I think they can I want
to see season 2 i can't say like i'm
excited to see it if there's i'm excited
excited i want to see it I'm excited
because I feel like if this is what they
can do on their first round and I
enjoyed this well enough maybe not be
perfect but I feel like it they can look
at what's going on I don't think
greening is an idiot not like he puts
Simpsons and Futurama together I think
he can look at the criticisms and stuff
and realize I'm doing this on Netflix
now okay I actually knew okay he was a
concrete snatcher all style of cop I
feel like he was already going that
route in the last three episodes yeah
like they were just like okay let's get
a story going
but somebody to that Castlevania anime
that just came out where it's like yeah
takes its time it's still good but like
hopefully now that they're just like
okay it's this to me is proof of concept
okay if the concept can work okay now
season two let's really open shit up and
I hope they do the same but cancel
really I can't wait for that
I really hope in season two the first
two episodes aren't just alright go on
this grand adventure there's bean
there's everybody okay back to the
kingdom I want them to get
Apple I want them to go out there I want
them discover secrets I want discover
there's a great plot
I want to game of Thrones we all split
up and they're going on yeah oh great
that'd be wonderful but they're going
like this you're a shaman behind of Game
of Thrones of different fantasies which
just opens it up so much and it's like I
stay in this one town really really
branch out so I'm hoping they do if
you're wondering whether or not to watch
this show I would say yes it does drag a
lot but there's always just enough to
kind of keep you going there's always
like the little carrot in front of you
why you keep going keep going it's like
you do get the carrot you know and it's
like you're glad you made that journey
just yeah you gotta travel because
perfect shows made for like you know
once a night throw an episode on take a
week couple weeks to watch it
binge watching it I don't think is
always the right move just cuz you see
the cracks much quicker yeah you see the
repetition a little bit more but but
then it's nice when they do very
something and they do kind of get away
from it you can't appreciate it even
more so yeah that's our take on it go
watch it see for yourself at out let us
know to good we've been hearing varying
things about like everyone I've talked
to they're always like yeah what's good
look clunky but I'm glad I stuck with it
like anything is what I get but they're
not the internet they're like that's
weird thing everybody I knew hated it
and then when I post it on my private
Facebook that I'm just like you know my
expectation Lord then all of a sudden I
had other people in my friends groups
coming out going oh yeah I love that
show it's really good yeah something I
don't know it's like a quite a split but
I think the people who really liked it
or just quiet about it maybe I think
it's it what do you think in terms of
first seasons do you think it's a better
start than Futurama yeah what do you
thought I think it's definitely better
first episode than future feature man
honestly last more than I'd like
like the dramas better than this first
season but it's like hearing the first
two seasons I'm just kind of like I
honestly from this available like watch
the first season of Simpsons again oh
well the first season round break only
for its time but yeah it's just like I
think this is a way stronger product
than either future
or the first season of our 1st season /
1st season yeah yeah I don't think
there's anything in this season of this
show that beats classic Futurama classic
senses at their higher like not even
close yet but I I mean that I think the
sparks there yeah feel like you could
get something really good yeah so sad oh
I see it going I keep going so I yeah
let us know what you think in the
comments below I actually don't know
ladies that we see YouTube videos saying
yeah this show sucks but then we talked
to people like yes okay so so let us
know what you think I mean I'm curious
what the reception of this show is so uh
that's about it we'll see you next time
later did not expect that much blood out
of an alpha
you